[Applaudissements]
mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché oui j'ai péché car de notre
dernière vidéo sur le megalodon on a dit
du mal de jurassic world et ça ça se
fait pas ça c'est un grand péché mes
bien chers abonnés alors il va falloir
que j'explique et j'ai longtemps cherché
quelle serait la meilleure façon
d'expliquer cette faute et là j'ai eu la
révélation l'illumination
je vais me retaper cette purge qui était
jurassique world 2 pauline kingdom et
oui je vais soigner le péché par le
péché exactement vous avez tout compris
alors on avait aussi dit qu'on ferait
pas de vidéo critiques sur jurassique
worlds mais ceci n'est pas une vidéo de
critiques de jure ainsi qu un buzz car
on va pas parler du contenu scientifique
du tout en finale ça va être juste moi
en train de souffrir en train de
regarder ce film parce qu'il faut
rappeler quand même le but de dbm kg
pénitence c'est quand même de me voir
souffrir
et quoi de plus douloureux que de voir
la saga jurassic park se faire massacrer
une fois de plus par une suite des plus
déplorables dangereux ainsi que j'incite
park iii était déjà franchement
douloureux mais la jurassic wande est
passé bien au delà de la barre du lourd
mais tout ça je vais l'expliquer
évidemment au fur et à mesure du
visionnage et puis davantage de jurassic
would say qui ne respectent plus peuplés
les règles de débogage et pénitence à
savoir la première règle est que le
contenu analysé doit être incroyablement
douloureux à regarder ou à analyser ou à
lire ou quoi que ce soit et surtout la
deuxième règle est que le contenu
analysé doit avoir plus de succès que
notre chaîne donc jurassique world 2
respecte parfaitement ces deux règles
il ya quand même quelque chose à
admettre au niveau des bons points sur
un site web c'est que c'est quand même
bien foutu les images sont belles et non
un enfant wallis date
attendez les gars on est dans un monde
où ça fait 15 ans qu'on a ramené les
dinosaures à la vie de mais qui nous dit
what is date
le mec il voit une ombre de 5 mètres de
haut passé dans les arbres en les
faisant bouger et il est encore là en
train de se demander qu'est ce que c'est
tu es venu sur une île chercher des
restes de dinosaures une île qu'on s'est
peuplé de dinosaures depuis 15 ans ii ou
du sort ou atys date tout tu sais pas ce
que c'est quoi et puis lui c'est pareil
là il est il ya ses potes qui sont en
train de me dionne rentrée il dit qu'il
n'entend pas mais dit tu crois pas que
cette époque le dise de rentrée c'est
précisément parce qu'un dinosaure
derrière toi
non mais t'es vraiment un gland à ce
point clichés du mec qui regardent la
menace pendant 15 secondes en criant oh
mon dieu non mais franchement
what is date et l'autre qui a encore
l'air surpris de voir un dinosaure à
jurassic world de pousser non mais c'est
exactement ça avait même été surpris de
voir un dinosaure aubagne et on n'avait
pas vu venir celle là genre il pensait
qu'ils étaient tous morts les morts de
quoi d'ailleurs
onfray de quoi ils seraient noirs les
dinosaures sur l'île puisque justement
le on a un jurassic warda ils ont pas
reparlé du truc de la lysine donc c'est
qu'a priori ils l'ont parfait la
déficience en lysine donc de quoi les
dinosaures seraient morts mais toute
façon
bon après big up pour avoir montré le
t-rex dans les 15 premières secondes du
film nabeul là je suis plutôt d'accord
avec l'appareil
mission du mozart 602 non franchement
impressionnant là moi je suis pour
je suis 100% pour bon alors là la
compagnie une gêne qui a envoyé les
proies
toute cette compagnie de mercenaires
rechercher de l'adn d'ado raptor dans
d'ado minutes s'est pas encore là nous
raptor a quand même vu trois de ses
employées se faire se faire défoncer la
gueule et mourir je me demande comment
ils vont justifier ça vous fait pas de
bilan la fin de l'année sur la quantité
de morts le génie
qui vous annonce la suite du film ça va
brûler ça va brûler ça va piquer comme
de la lave en fusion savent appliquer
comme de la lave en fusion
ah oui au fait on vous a pas dit mais il
y avait un volcan en éruption
ça fait 15 ans qu'on a construit deux
parcs qui compte des milliards de
dollars sur isla nublar on s'était pas
rendu compte que c'était un volcan merde
au les cons au les conquois deux parcs à
plusieurs milliards de dollars et on a
oublié de faire une analyse de la
géologie du terrain et on s'est pas
rendu compte que c'était un volcan qui
était seulement rando rnic non mais
franchement dommage c'est bien qu'on
construit des parcs super cher on a
construit un parc super g super cher à
vulcania mais c'est vrai c'est parce que
les volcans sont le coeur de la traction
pas parce que pas parce qu'on a voulu
faire autre chose par dessus
là on a vraiment valence et du fric à
construire un truc il était presque
condamnés et dangereux en plus caméo de
jeff goldblum
alors je vais vous terminez le débat
pour vous la seule raison pour laquelle
on ne garderait pas les dinosaures c'est
pour la simple et bonne raison que ces
dinosaures n'ont rien à [ __ ] là c'est
une espèce invasive sur cette île
les dinosaures ont été apportées la part
l'homme et foot et foot son écosystème
en l'air il y avait déjà des espèces qui
existait sur cette île naturellement et
le fait qu'ils aient des dinosaures sur
isla du dollar fout en l'air
l'écosystème
donc si l'écosystème goy disparaît pour
de toute façon il n'y a pas de raison de
sauver les dinosaures plus que le reste
d'ailleurs s'il fallait sauver quoi que
ce soit ce serait plutôt le reste en
réalité donc fin des débats les
dinosaures doivent disparaître
ah et on re découvre clair clair qui est
vos découvertes comme elle l'était avant
alors ce bizarre parce que elle est
passée
le mans deux responsables de plusieurs
dizaines de morts et de centaines de
blessés à tranquille et libre dans une
petite association qui est cherche à
sauver des dinosaures donc voilà
mesdames et messieurs sept personnes
dont la compétence a été ma compétence a
été la source de plusieurs morts et de
blessés et de traumatismes parce qu'il y
avait quand même des dizaines de
milliers de personnes soit disant sur
l'île au moment de l'incident est libre
elle n'a même pas un petit bracelet elle
a même pas un petit bracelet à son
poignet ou à son à sa cheville pour
indiquer sa position à la police voilà
un individu dangereux dans la nature la
caisse qu'elle qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ni
pourquoi pourquoi les parents cool
pourquoi on parle pas des 10 millions de
procès qu'elle a au cul c'est quand même
un truc de foule ça donc déjà la logique
bug la cohérence avec le précédent film
juste la cohérence avec le précédent
film lebanon on emmerde
alors déjà que j'étais pas un gros fan
premier jurat si quoi mais ce film déjà
a décidé qu'il ne respecterait même pas
jurassique web puisque au final on fait
comme si rien ne s'était passé
voilà
ces trois notes vous ont été offertes
nostalgie facile nostalgie facile parce
que c'est plus facile d'attirer les gens
avec la nostalgique avec un contenu
réellement intéressant évidemment on n'a
jamais entendu parler de monsieur le
coup d'avant donc bah qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va réinventer l'histoire
bien sûr elle et suivez moi clair vous
expliquer tout ce qu'il faut pour
expliquer ce trou scénaristique
gigantesque était monsieur lockwood et
pourquoi on n'a jamais entendu parler
dans la saga jurassic park
nous avons une île parfaite pour les
dinosaures islas au renard
voilà on va déplacer les dinosaures sur
une nouvelle île parce que parce que ça
suffit pas de [ __ ] en l'air
l'écosystème d'une semaine il faut
déplacer ces espèces invasives sur une
nouvelle voie là et on va sauver 11
espèces
bon on va sauver 11 espèces en prenant
qu'un couple de chaque façon arche de
noé
histoire d'assurer une consanguinité
formidable mais mais sinon on va fonder
en espèces va les sauver au moins pour
les dix prochaines années après on verra
mais juste assez pour [ __ ] en l'air
l'écosystème de cette île là voilà on va
comme ça on aura foutu en l'air deux il
est formidable john's de peste lise
crichton à l'aps
alors là il vient de balancer la pire
bombe sur le scénario du film john l'a
dit ces animaux n'ont pas besoin de
notre protection et vous savez quand il
l'a dit il l'a dit à l'ap hm de jurassic
park de the lost world
vous vous rappelez du ainsi que park 2
the lost world 1 c'est le film qui a
exactement le même scénario que celui là
alors c'est un problème pourquoi cette
citation de john amende parce que jon
hamm homme il le dit à la fin de the
lost world de cette phrase dans une
interview télé donc ça veut dire que
toutes les erreurs commises pendant
jurassique pas durant le film jurassic
world 2 ont déjà été faites dans
jurassic park 2 et qu'ils l'admettent
c'est surtout ça le truc c'est jean
ainsi que world pour soi-disant
fonctionner parce qu'on ignorait que je
récite pas 2 et 3 avaient eu lieu mais
là on ignore pas qu ils ont eu lieu
puisque il vient de citer une phrase qui
vient directement de la fin du film
jurassic park 2
donc ça veut dire que fallen king dôme
se passe après jurassic park 2 et donc
toutes les erreurs qui sont commises
dans jurassic world deux ont déjà été
commises dans jurassic park 2 donc ils
refont exactement les mêmes conneries et
en plus l'autre problème c'est qu'il
existe une autre île avec des dinosaures
qu'on découvre dans jurassic park de
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ces
conneries
ils disent qu'ils vont retrouver une île
pour déplacer les dinosaures alors
qu'ils ont déjà une autre île qui est
basiquement bourré de dinosaures mais
non on choisit pas en parler on fait
comme si ça n'avait jamais eu lieu
mais par contre on bouge on vous sent
une citation du même film
je suis désolé mais si vous ignorez que
l'existence de jurassic park de vous
ignorer la résomption de john a band qui
est soudainement devenu un écolo et vous
ignorez la phrase qu'il a dite à la fin
du film
ou alors me citer cette phrase mais dans
ce cas là pour faire comme si l'histoire
de jurassic park ii avait eu lieu mais
faites pas comme prenez pas que ce qui
vous intéresse pas mais alors du coup on
peut comparer tous films à jurassic park
2 voilà on recrute une équipe on va sur
l'île on découvre qu'il ya une équipe
parallèle qui veut prendre les
dinosaures à des fins personnelles pour
en refaire quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
envie qu'ils en fassent ils vont ramener
les dinosaures son continent et
bizarrement il ya un carnivore qui va
devenir complètement berzerk que sur le
continent il se met à tuer tout le monde
bilan c'est une histoire qu'on n'a
jamais vu ça c'est des conneries qu'ils
n'ont jamais été fait
voilà pourquoi j'aime pas ce film ce
film vous prend pour des glands ce film
crois que les fans de jurassic park ont
oublié la saga jurassic park
voilà le nommer on va on va faire comme
si rien ne s'était passé mais on va
quand même faire des références à des
trucs qui sont passés banon soit tu fais
comme si s'était pas passé soit à est
évidemment clair retourne voir owen qui
en est toujours au même point c'est à
dire que c'est ce que juin un mec qui
vit dans une caravane
voilà et on reprend les mêmes et on
recommence littéralement
on reprend littéralement les mêmes leur
commencé exactement la même scène
quasiment mot
pour vous que celle de jurassic web un
personnage ont pas évolué d'un pouce
ils s'aiment mais pas trop ils sont
ensemble et séparés ils vivent leur vie
chacun de leur côté mais voilà plan cul
avec un avantage non ça rien ce que
c'est que leurs conditions
c'est compliqué sur facebook voilà bien
sûr qui va le laisser crever l'a essayé
de le bouchon au moins quatre fois deux
par exemple t'as pas vu le film avant où
il faut leur passer la abbaoui et comme
blue se transforme soudainement pikachu
donc blues c'est le raptor qui a essayé
de boucher owen après à peine 20 minutes
de film dans le précédent ne sais pas si
vous vous rappelez et là soudainement il
va falloir que dans ce film blue
devienne une sorte de pikachu
c'est-à-dire un chien animal serviable
et bien élevé qui va jamais mais jamais
de la vie
essayez de le copier owen une seule fois
alors du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait bien
on réécrit l'histoire de plus voilà donc
comme je le disais ce film a tellement
pas de respect pour la saga jurassic
park qu'ils emmerdent eux-mêmes de films
dont il est censé être la suite
c'est-à-dire jurassique oil ce film n'a
pas de respect pour jurassic world et
c'est peu dire déjà aucun respect pour
jurassic world qui n'avait lui-même
aucun respect pour lui racing part donc
en gros ah oui j'avais pas parler de cet
improbable tricératops ouais ouais je
sais même pas si c'est censé être un
tricératops enfin la seule raison pour
laquelle il a les cornes qui pointe vers
le haut comme ça c'est juste pour
empaler le raptor à la fin
sinon il n'y a aucune logique
anatomiques ou scientifique derrière
ceux là je sais pas si le match a
derrière elle c'est censé être un outil
au ghana tor donc cette crête bizarre si
c'est censé être un diction venator
c'est pas le bon chrono venator c'est
sain c'est un cetain spinosaures idée
donc il est censé avoir un crâne
beaucoup plus crocodiliens que qu'est ce
qu'on peut voir la nostalgie facile il
vous présente la scène du brachiosaure
de jurassic park a à peine 20 un plein
remodifier on allait même si j ai un peu
datés jurassic park inde date de 1993
celui là est tout récent à peu près
aussi subtile queue de pie des anneaux
nyon en dessous de vos yeux voilà harry
harrach où une larme à recht une larme
avec ceux avec cette facilité
déconcertante
donc non denses et une autre raison pour
laquelle j'aime pas slim pas ce film est
difficile à regarder c'est parce qu'il
est absolument
il veut tellement vous faire chialer
avec de la nostalgie que veut bien c'est
fait avec tellement plus de subtilité
c'est surtout ça s'est fait avec
tellement peu de subtilité que je n'en
prends vraiment l'intérêt
et puis d'ailleurs parlons-en de ce
brachiosaures depuis quand le
brachiosaure est libre dans la nature
depuis qu il ya des dinosaures libre
dans la nature sur cette île parce que
si vous vous rappelez jurassique world à
ya que le t-rex l'anneau minus et blue
qui sont libres à la fin du film et les
ptérosaures donc 2 ou le brachiosaure se
baladent en liberté dans le parc de
houle le brachiosaure et en dehors de
son enclos de dire si c'est arrivé quand
c'est arrivé comment c'est arrivé
pourquoi c'est n'importe quoi regarder
regarder cette série il ya des
dinosaures partout il ya des dinosaures
partout sur l'île alors que basiquement
il en avait aucun de libre à la fin du
jurassique web
alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
coupé le courant sur toute l'île ils se
sont dit que c'était une bonne idée de
couper le courant sur toute nil à la fin
du 1 c'est quoi qu'est ce qui s'est
produit
voyez la cohérence
ce avec le la cohérence avec le premier
jurassique web n'est même pas assuré
quoi aucune référence gratuite au
premier et sonné ce n'en est qu'une
parmi des milliers à mesdames et
messieurs voici le pari ionix le
baryonyx c'est à l'épreuve de la lave
regardez mais regardez sa voix à août
j'ai pris un peu de lave sur la tête
c'est dommage et surtout le baryonyx qui
a tellement la dalle 1 que malgré le
fait qu'il se prend de la lave sur la
tête ils continuent à vouloir les
bouffer et oui la non mais regardez moi
je viens de passer ça fait toute ma mère
quoi la face voilà sérieusement tu es
affamés au point de vouloir bouffer des
gens à travers un rideau de lave en
fusion quoi mais j'aimais vraiment et on
est censés croire ça surtout on est
censé trouver ça crédible
à
owen doit crier deux fois courait pour
qu'ils se mettent à courir
voyez le volcan en éruption vous voyez
la direction opposée fallait vraiment
vous expliquer qu'il fallait courir dans
la direction opposée
deux fois sérieusement et owen qui
pouvais à peine tenir debout il ya deux
minutes maintenant une vraie mobylette
je suis un peu sceptique du coup de l'an
kilos d'or qui galope marcher vite à la
rigueur mais et qui galope non bon moi
ils ont pas fait les sauropodes qui
galope ça pour le coup les sauropodes
marche pas alors les ankylose hors jeu
ça m'étonne un peu et voilà et on nous
introduit encore un nouveau dinosaure
cette fois le carme corus est alors de
carnotaurus il a aussi cette
particularité comme le baryonyx ne pas
avoir de n'avoir absolument aucun sens
des priorités
c'est à dire que lui plutôt que de
plutôt que d'essayer de couvrir pour
sauver sa vie et ben non il a faim il a
peint aussi et il va essayer de tuer un
gros dinosaures alors qu'il a des
humains tous frais payés juste à côté de
lui des gens si ça c'est censé être
crédible bah je suis désolé mais ça
l'est pas non à aucun moment ne vous en
faites pas c'est pas le seul car niveau
requis aucun sens de priorité car voici
venir
voilà le fameux tyrannosaure le fameux
tyrannosaure rex mcinnes a un qui vous
sauve vos héros au dernier moment et qui
n'a absolument aucun sens des priorités
et qu'il est qui ne bouffent même pas
[ __ ] il ne bouffent même pas sa proie
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a tué ce
carnotaurus
pourquoi il le tue si c'est même pas
pour le bouffer et puis c'est quoi cette
nuée ardente là je croyais que c'était
un volcan exclusif on a vu de la lave
couler la fluide comme tous savaient
pourquoi les volcans sont explosives
parce que la lave est trop épaisse que
du coup la pression s'évacue par
explosion
et là vous nous manquez vous nous
montrez un vélo un volcan qui a une la
complètement fluide et juste derrière
une nuée ardente va te faire [ __ ] film
tu es le prometheus de la salle g
jurassique le aliens covenante
sérieusement owen y survit à cette nuée
ardente au n à poil dans une chose dans
une nuée ardente survit malgré tout
pourquoi pas alors je tiens juste à vous
faire noter le tir est que ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure
porter les cicatrices de son combat avec
l'inde ominus qu'on avait vu dans le
premier film
on est bien d'accord 1 vous allez voir
qu'elle tirait que s'ils ont capturé les
méchants vous verrez qu'elle est le
t-rex qu'ils ont capturé les méchants et
mais je vous dirais surtout m'expliquer
quand du coup ils l'ont capturé parce
que là je vois pas le t-rex était avec
owen claire et le monsieur je sais plus
son nom l'informaticien et dassault
couilles il va être capturé par les
méchants et on sait pas où nous comment
téléportation facilités scénaristiques
je veux le savoir
je vous laisse devenir homme a
finalement on a survécu à l'explosion
finalement il ya peut-être des
dinosaures qui vont pouvoir survivre à
cette éruption volcanique référence à
jurassic park 2 qui n'existe pas se
disant voilà voilà donc la scène du camp
avec tous les mini avec tous les
militaires et puis les dinosaures
capturés on n'a jamais vu ça non plus
bah oui parce que de vouloir sortir les
dinosaures de sept-îles est la meilleure
des idées du monde
comme l'animal comme la pire idée dans
toute la longue et triste histoire des
mauvaises idées
et encore une meilleure idée c'est de
vouloir arracher les dents ou même
dinosaure
jamais de la vie une borne de stégosaure
ça ressemble à ça jamais de la vie
donc le plan c'est d'arriver à balancer
le camion dans le bateau sans se faire
repérer bonne chance allez-y les gars et
surtout ayez l'air naturel quand vous
balancera le camion à l'arrière du
bateau surtout fait comme si tout était
normal
je vous parlais des oignons tout à
l'heure et de comment vous les piles et
sous les yeux pour vous tirer des larmes
un pur prendrez bien un petit peu de
subtilité la halle et un deuxième
service qu'est ce que c'est triste
il n'y avait absolument aucun moyen que
les dinosaures échappent à ce cataclysme
non à part ici ici ici là est peut-être
un peu là aussi messi n'ont aucun moyen
aucun moyen on a créé un peu nouveau
dinosaure surpuissant plus petit que
l'admin us beaucoup moins puissant tout
aussi lent aussi intelligent mais qui
n'a plus les capacités cool comme celle
de sentir les infrarouges ou encore de
devenir invisible mais il est vachement
bien cet adorateur puis comme la demi nu
c'était à peu près aussi intelligent que
les raptors j'en passe qui vous aurait
empêché de de le dresser au final cette
scène qui consiste à soigner un
dinosaure blessé n'a jamais été vu non
plus dans jurassic park 2 absolument
jamais donc le grand projet c'est de
prendre du sens de tyrannosaure pour
l'injecter dans celui dans le corps du
vélociraptor qui manque de globules
rouges
je ne sais pas jusqu'à quel point les
deux sont compatibles mais il va
normalement pouvait injecter du sang
comme ça il faut quand même le prêter
pour filer pour qu'ils aient plus
d'anticorps parce que sinon vais les
deux lots de sang vont complètement
complètement s'entretuer c'est à dire
que les anticorps du direct vont
paraître très content de ne se retrouver
entourés d'antigènes le velociraptor
mais bon au et regarder quel tir à nos
horizons capturés est ce que ce serait
pas le tyrannosaure avec les cicatrices
de son combat contre olemps de minutes
vous savez celui qui était en train de
courir pour échapper à l'explosion du
volcan et qui a été rattrapé normalement
par une nuée ardente
je me demande comment ils l'ont capturé
celui là
cette vision domaine sautant à travers
la bouche du tyrannosaure était tout à
fait crédible
[Rires]
donc est-ce que j'ai eu peur pour lui
presque
j'ai eu les jetons qui se fasse attraper
par les sidiya sérieusement et
maintenant nous suivons la petite fille
qui se prend pour james bond et va nous
faire une opération survie et espionnage
en dépit en dépit de son oncle et va
découvrir que son nom de ce même mois
signe son deuxième petit c'est se met
elle à découvrir que le méchant monsieur
est en fait un traître qui veut vendre
les dinosaures pour faire des armes
alors pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais du
coup aussi cette petite fille est une
guerrière alors il va pas à m'expliquer
quelques-unes de ces réactions parce que
on verra ça en temps voulu donc on est
en train de nous montrer un laboratoire
un laboratoire de génétique avec des
oeufs de dinosaures qui doivent
certainement contenir des dinosaures
d'où la question mais pourquoi quand
s'emmerde
pourquoi est ce qu'on sait emmerder à
aller chercher tous ces dinosaures sur
l'île alors qu'on avait tout ce qu'il
fallait sur place à la maison on a le
docteur où on à ces données alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'emmerde à aller
chercher des dinosaures directement sur
l'île ils disent que c'est pour faire de
l'argent pour pouvoir financer leurs
opérations je suis d'accord mais combien
ça a coûté cette opération sur l'île et
puis vas-y qu'on continue de vazy qu'on
continue de réécrire l'histoire de blu
en nous montrant que blue c'est gentil
c'est pikachu elle obéit très bien elle
a toujours été gentille blouin
on l a juste essayé de me bouffer mais
c'est pas grand chose
et puis on lui fait des grands yeux
surtout blue auquel nerfs plus gentille
et puis on lui donne de l'empathie
tableaux de genre genre elle veut pas
essayé de poignarder dans le dos je veux
dire les légeoises aux trois cantons et
dresse on est d'accord on est d'accord
que ça marche jusqu'à un certain point
mais pas au point de le montrer de
l'empathie quoi donc faut arrêter après
ça je suis d'accord qu'on peut dresser
les velociraptor puisque après tout ils
sont trés paul ii d'oiseaux croix
mais au bout d'un moment montrer de
l'empathie ou une figure humaine
ça me semble un peu trop là ils essaient
de faire genre il est triste mais en fin
d'année une expression de la tristesse
chez le velociraptor doit être un peu
différente maintenant un peu bon bref
l'ado raptor a besoin d'une maman sinon
on pourra pas d'adressé à part que wayne
n'a jamais n'a jamais eu besoin de
mamans pour dresser les raptor donc je
deux ou deux coups sûrs cette logique
encore une fois on se le demande
suffit de l'apprendre dès le berceau et
puis de l'imprégner de lui faire croire
qu'elle est humaine et puis voilà votre
de votre un orateur est prêt c'est à
dire comme on fait exactement comme on
crée avec les oiseaux poids exactement
comme on nous montre que owen a fait
avec les raptor pourquoi ça ne
marcherait pas avec nadau raptor on ne
vous l'expliquera jamais et encore une
référence gratuite
la chèvre de jurassic park 1 on vient
totalement de voir le t-rex faire tomber
des morceaux de béton en tapant contre
sa cage
on vient de tellement de voir qu'il
était capable de s'évader mais non non
non tout va bien tout est logique et
absolument aucun problème
cette conversation n'a aucune raison
d'être si méchant monsieur ne vient pas
demander à owen de dresser ces ados
raptor la seule conversation logique que
vous êtes censé avoir à ce niveau là
c'est bonjour owen ged
j'ai des ados raptor est ce que tu veux
venir les dresser et d'ailleurs s'il
avait eu cette conversation avec owen
dès le début du film et vaillant n'ai
jamais eu besoin d'aller sur l'île pour
aller chercher blue ils ont juste eu à
aller chercher aux veines
bonjour bien dressés no 1 aux raptor
c'est pour quoi faire je te le dirai pas
où il y aurait fallu lui mentir puisque
apparemment il est mythomane le mec donc
voilà dans l'économie tonné
au bout d'un moment owen un peu à court
d'argent aurait probablement fini par
céder mademoiselle macgyver et encore
elle est encore en train de faire la
super espionne super survival donc
j'insiste là dessus mais ça va avoir son
importance
j'insiste beaucoup là dessus mais ça va
avoir son importance ni survival grimpe
sur les doigts elle est capable de faire
de ce manoir son manoir c'est son petit
jouet quoi à l'eni ce qu'elle veut elle
va où elle veut comme elle veut
aucun souci mais vous allez voir que aux
seuls moments où ça pourrait être utile
elle ne s'en servira pas là on entre
vraiment dans le moment du film qui a
commencé à me faire taper la tête contre
les murs là vous allez voir le pas qui
c'est fade aux ors et ne pas fixer falot
de l'ordre
sa seule raison d'exister c'est de taper
sa tête c'est de taper sa tête
absolument partout c'est à qui ses fans
aux orres n'existe que pour ça pour
foncer partout on s'est vraiment
l'apogée du dinosaure fonction quoi on a
vu tout à l'heure les carnivores les
carnivores il ne servait qu'à boucher ne
servait qu'à essayer de vous fait clair
il ne servait qu'à essayer de boucher
owen il ne servait qu'à bouffer l'autre
car nos torts pour sauver owain donc les
cas les carnivores ils servent qu'à
bouffer ses des dinosaures fonctions ils
n'ont aucun instinct de survie ne savent
pas échappé à un volcan mais par contre
ils savent boucher et là le pas qui
c'est fall aux normes
c'est un autre dinosaure fonction sauf
que celui-là il ne sert qu'à foncer dans
les murs ou a foncé dans les jambes
c'est tout c'est pareil ici rien faire
d'autre il sait rien faire d'autre c'est
admis qu'ils font dans les murs et dans
les heures et dans les gens on va la sas
sas et ses confluents parce que c'est ma
paresse d'écriture d'une bas et puis le
2 ça réduit les animaux simple utilité
qu'ils ont pour les pour les humains
qu'ont donc ce film là qu'ils essaient
de prétendre être écolo parce qu'il nous
montre des gens qui essaient de sauver
les dinosaures parce que c'est beau de
sauver les espèces nous montre des
écolos qui veulent juste réintroduire
des espèces invasives dans d'autres
environnements et nous montre des écolos
qui essaye de sauver des millions
ne sont que des fonctions voilà donc des
animaux qui n'ont même pas un
comportement d'animaux normaux donc non
raté petits films ratés petit film belle
tentative de vouloir faire sans voir
d'être écolo mais non merci pas qui
c'est falot zorkons comme un balai
j'espère qu'on te reverra quand on aura
d'autres trucs à défoncer à grands coups
de boule dit hinds
la scène d'introduction de l'inde aux
raptor avec sa musique
la définition même de over the tough
découvrez nadeau raptor qu'est ce qu'il
a de spécial
honnêtement c'est un lézard merci tout
ce qui l'est c'est juste un [ __ ] de
lézard il est mal proportionné on sait
pas si les bipèdes ou quadrupèdes
il a un plus opposable qui ne sert
jamais à rien ça ressemble juste à un
gros varan
regardez moi ça n'a rien de particulier
n'est pas particulièrement gros il sait
pas se rendre invisible il ya aucune
capacité particulière que celle d'être
d'être un tueur fou psychopathe quel est
l'intérêt de cet animal et la petite
bande doré sur le côté qui nous rappelle
golden freezer de dragon ball donc c'est
clairement le la façon la plus bête et
méchante de montrer que quelque chose
est plus important que quelque chose
d'autre
voilà l'ado raptor est mieux que l'ado
minus parce qu'il a une petite bande
doré sur le côté ces colonnes raptor et
on en arrive au point culminant du film
alors j'ai dit tout à l'heure un que ce
film reproduisait exactement le même
scénario que jurassic park 2 avec les
gens qui produisait les exactement les
mêmes conneries que dans jurassic park 2
alors là je suis désolé je me suis
trompé
il s'apprête à en faire une qui est
encore pire il fait une connerie qui est
encore plus tellement une connerie c'est
tellement évident que c'est une connerie
que ça en devient grotesque quoi c'est
vraiment la scène la plus grotesque du
film regardez-la de raptor of the bulma
que le jeu fait sourire à la caméra cc
du cartoon
c'est du cartoon là c'est le chasseur et
le maire en train de vouloir arracher
une dent à venir à lui ajouter les
oreilles de lapin l'adorateur et vous
avez peu de bonifier qui est en train de
se payer la gauche est en train de se
payer la true ii
mr et hop le petit sourire quoi
sérieusement et ça vous voulez me faire
croire que ça faut que je le prenne au
sérieux et surtout ce qui va se passer
maintenant regarder ce qui va se passer
maintenant là le film qui depuis le
début est gentil comme tout bann bien
nous montrer l'agora tort en train de
trancher un bras pour bien établir que
l'ado raptor il est méchant
non je suis désolé l'acd d'une dune
c'est de la légitime défense est
d'essayer quand même de lui arracher une
dent à vif l'autre et puis de 2 bat
comment tu veux qu'on retrouve cette
scène dramatique après ce que tu viens
de montrer qu'on est bien comment tu
veux qu'on trouve une scène dramatique
après nous avoir montré que l'ado raptor
basiquement c'était c'était un petit
farceur
il faisait des petits sourires en coin
donc là c'est vraiment la scène qui m'a
donné envie de me barrer parce que d'une
part tout ce qui précédait été très
chiant et voilà on vient de se prendre
20 minutes de blabla et de vente aux
enchères donc on s'en fout totalement
et puis là on se tape une scène
tellement grotesque que non car ce
monsieur en composant le code code a
totalement pas marcher 1
re regarder bien je vous repasse la
scène du code
voilà des digicodes il allait voir que
le code est totalement pas marcher quand
il a appuyé sur le bouton 1 de cette
auquel le 3 il a marché qu'une fois et
le dies n'a pas marché du tout donc
jamais de la vie cette porte d'ascenseur
ne devrait se fermait bien essayé mais
une fois de plus c'est raté l'inde au
rapport qui réouvre le truc par accident
parce qu'il faut bien que les méchants
meurt un mets sérieusement on vous prend
pour du marron du jambon et la
révélation ultime
en fait la fille était un clown on s'en
fout on s'en fout littéralement ça n'a
aucun l'espèce da ponte
ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance on
s'en fout vais essayer de nous faire
passer ça pour la révélation du film le
twist c'est tellement un énorme bruit et
banon est rentable je veux dire vous
avez à peine fait du build up sur ça et
ça n'a aucune conséquence
enfin si ça aura une conséquence mais
une conséquence ri tellement débiles
qu'on en reparlera en temps et voilà et
une fois de plus on répète jurassique
ouais ben voilà le docteur henry on
remballe tout c'est tout s'est joué
direction la suite jacques sion le
jurassique world droit exactement comme
l'ange racing
oui libérer un velociraptor qu'elle
grandit desquels énormissime bonne idée
franchement n'auraient rien pu faire de
plus intelligent parce que c'est tout ce
qui manquait à ce film un velociraptor
en liberté
[Musique]
hélas le film se transforme maintenant
survival horror donc on a eu droit aux
films catastrophes et maintenant ça
devient à survival horror dans un manoir
avec évidemment des grosses références
putassière à jurassic park un puisqu'on
voit la douleur l'ado raptor tapez 2
tapez de sa griffe quand il est agacé
exactement comme les velociraptor du
premier de jurassic park d'un dame ans
l'ado raptor dont on nous a tellement
vanté les mérites est con comme un
ballet pas capable de voir qu'il ya des
images juste en dessous de lui humains
qui doivent d'ailleurs ch l'ail et la
mort parce que s'appeler juste et deux
jours qui court dans tous les sens a
essayé d'échapper à des volcans et à des
dinosaures carnivores qui nous inquiète
tous faire que boucher bref tient ont
rétabli l'électricité ce qui met en
danger nos protagonistes
je me demande dans quel film j'ai déjà
vu ça 1 c'était la fille qui passe un
quart d'heure à regarder l'adorateur à
travers la vitre avant de se mettre à
crier attention alors l'inde aux raptor
poursuit la petite natte aux raptor
monte les escaliers pour une raison
qu'on ignore n'arrive jamais à la
rattraper l'un d'orateur et dans le
couloir
nador à tort on rentre dans le couloir
la petite se dirige vers le monte charge
on a le droit un gros clin d'oeil
putassier à jurassic park 1
l'ado raptor qui vient de défoncer une
porte est incapable de passer à travers
le monde charles
pourquoi parce que scénario cette
glissade inutile vous été offert par
owen a trop la classe
et alors voici la scène la fameuse scène
cette gamine qui depuis le début nous
fait du survival d'enfer c'est une super
espionne elle connaît par coeur son
manoir à elle connaît toutes les
cachettes la meilleure cachette qu'elle
trouve c'est dans sa chambre sous un
drap dans sa chambre sous un drap genre
de cette maison ce manoir gigantesque
n'a pas de coffres-forts non non ll bas
dans la chambre sous un drap et là on
retrouve lingots raptor sur le toit et
pour quelles raisons ou quelles raisons
mais juste pour avoir une super image
cool de l'inde aux raptor en train de
crier devant la lune parce que
l'adorable il était dans le manoir
alors on sait pas pourquoi mme d'un seul
coup ils se retrouvent dehors alors
qu'il cherchait la petite pour quelles
raisons l'ado raptor à la poursuite de
la gamine sort du manoir et bien tout ça
la petite qui d'un seul coup passe de
jeu c'est pas par la petite qui d'un
seul coup pas de super ce super reine du
survival enfants débiles cachée sous des
draps quand elle a peur et l'ado raptor
qui sort alors qu'il est à la poursuite
de la petite à l'intérieur du manoir
c'est sensé nous mener à cette scène la
scène que vous avez vues dans le dans le
trailer encore avec nadia jura c'est pas
un donc le raptor qu'ici ouvrir les
portes
donc cette scène elle est censée vous
ramener à la scène que vous avez vu dans
le trailer cette scène qui était super
cool elle était absolument effrayante
effectivement dans le trailer on savait
pas trop ce qu'ils conduisaient à cette
situation de maintenant on le sait donc
cette scène c'est la scène du bras de
l'inde aux raptor ici autant par dessus
le lit de la gamine donc évoquant tous
les monstres de l'enfance évidemment
d'une vision de cauchemar
et cette scène pourquoi elle était cool
dans le trailer m'a justement c'est
parce qu'on était supposément à la place
de la gamine c'est à dire qu'on vient de
se réveiller en gros on ne sait pas ce
qui s'est passé avant mais d'un seul
coup on se retrouve pas ça se montre
quittant ses griffes ses énormes dans
vers nous et ça c'est effectivement
effrayant pourquoi cette scène devient
soudainement ridicule eh ben c'est parce
que quand on sait comment elle a fini là
on sait qu'elle a fini date parce
qu'elle a pris la décision grotesque de
venir se cacher sous le cacher sous les
draps d'un dinosaure probablement le
plus dangereux de tous les dinosaures et
on sait que l'ado raptor on sait d'où
vient la daurade tort il vient du toit
alors que de base ils n'étaient pas
censés venir du toit donc ni rentrer par
la fenêtre comme un monstre dans les ans
les cauchemars pour enfants sauf que il
n'est pas censé venir de la fenêtre
à aucun moment donc voilà une scène du
trailer qui était très très marquante
devient une scène probablement une des
scènes les plus ridicules du fils du
coup owen ex machina une balle de bâle
iii bâle iii balle l'un de raptor est à
genoux mesdames et messieurs le
dinosaure hop on est censé avoir peur
au moins l'un d'eux me lui savait la
politesse de résister à plusieurs salves
de mitrailleuses dans la langue aux
raptor est amené à genoux avec 3 bastos
scénario oblige ce fusil n'avait que
trois bastos
[Rires]
mais heureusement après le web x makeena
il y a blue ex machina
vas-y pikachu à l'attak et pendant ce
temps-là owen blessé pikachu se démerder
parce que parfois c'est pas de raison
qu'on est blue cette fois comme si on
était censé avoir un lien extrêmement
fort avec ce dinosaure
j'ai même pas comment il tient encore se
tient ce lien avec ce dinosaure pas si
au final blue à chaque fois qu'elle voit
owen est là que des emmerdes
il faut bien dire les choses blue à
chaque fois qu'elle voit owen soit elle
se prend une piquouse soit elle prend
une opération sans anesthésie soit bref
à chaque fois qu'il ya aucun moyen que
blue n'associe pas la présence de wayne
avec des emmerdes le lien avec de la
douleur à chaque fois qu'elle voit owen
à chaque fois que yoann tend la main
vers elle soit disant pour la calmer
c'est que blue va s'en prendre une soit
par l'un d'eux me bus soit par
acquisition par n'importe quoi l'ado
raptor ne s'est toujours pas grimper à
une échelle locale
non y'a aucun moyen que blue soit le
gentil animal à son pépère qu'on essaie
de nous faire croire que je suis désolé
jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie blue est un gentil
chien chien à quoi déjà qu'elle n'était
pas un gentil chien chien lent qu'une
précédente mais même si tu oublies ce
qui se passe dans une précédente
c'est pas possible que vous soit aussi
obéissante et aussi dévoué à owen que ça
owen est une source dans merde depuis le
début les y arriver dimanche deuxième
meilleure idée du monde j'ai pas tu
voudrais pas lui dire d'aller attaquer
un truc qui se trouveraient leur super
loin non plutôt que de lui dire
l'attaqué owen qu'est ce que c'est que
cette idée à la con c'est à dire et
doudou vous avez la coordination pour
cette idée m'énerve
et voilà pourquoi le tricératops à l'ego
cornes dressé vers le haut juste pour
que le [ __ ] d'ado raptor sent pas le
dessus et que vous et que blue s'en sort
les dents longues mais voilà
comme si de rien n'était et là on
remarque que ce crâne fossilisé
particulièrement robuste normalement ça
ne me dire tu vois les fissures qui a
dedans tu te dis que bon quand même si
tu poses un truc trop lourd dessus ça
risque quand même de s'effondrer le
moment dans le crâne il reste comme ça
sans aucun souci mais il faut un
quatrième acte à ce film donc on va
ressortir les violons ni madame une
encore une petite couche de subtilité
par dessus ça tous les dinosaures bombay
si on ne fait rien alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ben on est l'hiver évidemment qu'on
est lui dire qu'ils y comprennent
tyrannosaure parce que c'est à dire
étant donné ce concédé
étant donné ce qu'on sait des carnivores
dans ce film à savoir qu'ils ne servent
qu'à être carnivores veut dire les
brachiosaures ne sert qu'à nous faire
couler les larmes les pâtissiers fallows
or ne sert qu'à foncer dans les murs et
dans les gens et les ti et les
carnivores ne servent qu'à boucher les
autres de dire évidemment que c'est une
grande idée de libérer les herbivores et
les carnivores touches en même temps
évidemment que ça va causer aucun
problème
évidemment qu'ils ne vont pas essayer de
s'entretuer ah bah tiens non ils
s'entretuent pas parce que là bas parce
que scénario mais oui le film bouton
pour ouvrir la porte c'est un gros
bouton rouge dans tous évidemment dans
tous les manoirs le bouton de la porte
du garage est un grand bouton rouge ne
le saviez vous pas et il faut un code
avec deux clés comme pour la bombe
atomique est évidemment qu'on appuie pas
sur le bouton rouge évidemment qu'on va
pas le dire depuis le début tout l'idée
de ce film c'est de vouloir sauver des
espèces qui de toute façon ne doivent
pas être sauvée parce que c'est des
espèces quand rien à [ __ ] là s'il nous
est invasive donc évidemment qu on
n'appuie pas sur un bouton rouge
mais ceci est sans compter sur cette
histoire de clonage bon on a su qu'elle
était si importante quand on nous a fait
cette révélation
comme quoi la politique est un clown
toutes celles et le aboutissants de
toute cette histoire de clonage et bien
c'est l'ouverture de la porte
et oui mesdames et oui messieurs la
petite a appuyé sur le bouton parce
qu'ils ont le droit de vivre
et oui nous aurons droit de vivre comme
elle et ça c'est vous moi c'est censé
être beau mais petite salle a fait de
toi une nos prières tuer la responsable
direct de la mort de trois personnes
[Applaudissements]
une deux et trois personnes minimum
parce que évidemment c'est sans compter
la quantité de gens qui vont se faire
bouffer par les dinosaures carnivores
puisque c'est tout ce qu'ils savent
faire et références gratuite à jurassic
park
la dernière je l'espère a dit non on a
au moins relâché 20 dinosaures dans la
nature ça va facilement prendre quatre
grosses journées avant qu'une bande de
chasseurs en quête de trophées ou que
l'armée ne les tue tous m'a vraiment là
on attendait on les a sauvés ce qui
évidemment tout le monde va comprendre
cette décision
on part du principe que qu'absolument
ans tous les gouvernements du monde vont
comprendre la décision de relâcher ces
dinosaures dans la nature
personne ne va essayer de les tuer on
voit là quatre jours plus tard tous ces
dinosaures furent abattus parce qu'ils
n'ont rien à [ __ ] là parce qu'il
représente une menace
parce que de toute façon on va pas
laisser les gens faire ce qu'ils veulent
relâché n'importe quelle saloperie
qu'ils veulent dans la nature sous
prétexte que booth et des animaux ses
jambes
voilà donc quatre jours plus tard il y
avait plus de dinosaures pas de
l'histoire
là cette image cette image du mozart sur
la plage est super cool
cette image du t-rex eux face aux lions
est super cool
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas eu ça
pourquoi est ce que le film commence pas
là pourquoi est ce qu'on nous a emmerdé
avec cette histoire
d'aucuns qui avait aucun intérêt au lieu
de nous montrer c'est super c'est super
situation et comment on aurait réglé ces
situations pourquoi les ptérosaures vol
libre dans la nature seulement
maintenant alors qu'ils étaient déjà
libre depuis le premier film et la
dernière image de ce film l'ultime
images que vous allez emporté en sortant
de la salle de cinéma
c'est l'image de blue il se dit qu'elle
va quand même se faire un seul cri casse
dalle en allant dans cette banlieue
voilà mesdames et messieurs c'était
jurassique bol ça a pris deux heures ça
a été dur mais je les fais quand même ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais pas fini a
des bonnes kg pénitence complètement
donc merci vous pouvez m'applaudir j'ai
complètement trahi ma parole que comme
quoi je ne ferai pas de critique de
jurassic world et du coup ça ça vaudra
bien un nouveau déblocage de pénitence
par ailleurs je suis à la recherche de
thème pour des bunkers et penny donc si
vous avez eu le courage d'écouter des
bagages et pénitence jusque là bas
félicitations vous en avez du courage et
surtout il vient de j'aimerais bien un
thème sur les fossiles et la
lithothérapie parce que j'ai beau
chercher je ne trouve pas d'article
vraiment complet sur le visage des
fossiles en hypnothérapie est justement
j'aimerais bien pouvoir aborder le sujet
donc allez-y lâchez-vous en commentaire
faites-moi pleuvoir les sites les plus
ésotériques et les plus incroyablement
what the fuck possible et puis je vous
dis à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo